hi guys I'm Noah Sentinel I'm here at
BuzzFeed I'm gonna be telling you about
my first experiences all right the first
cell phone okay so my parents were never
on board with the idea of us having like
cell phones but I was lucky because when
I was 11 I went to a performing arts
school that was really far away from
where we lived so I never really far
away but far enough away that I had to
take the train to school public transit
so they bought me a Verizon chocolate
you can slide it up and you could text
you slide it back down a little touched
on it it's fantastic first cell phone
first aim account name ah oh god what
was my first day I got me no no a GC at
aol.com I used to love that that's where
I used to get all my music from the top
the top ten top five
I remember pwned the replay was on that
and like one two step and they put the
videos up and I was so cool you know I
think Hilary Duff was on that all the
time as well the best first date so this
was when I lived at the W the W Hotel
resident side has a really cool rooftop
suite pool big W she'd come over you
know late afternoon sometime close to
sunset there just before and I said
bring a book and we traded I gave her
Celestine Prophecy and she gave me you
are the one like ooh flaxen and we read
for like three hours
I loved being sentimental and
remembering things it's like literally
in a sentimentalist and that's all I do
so this is fantastic first pet I think
it was a rabbit named princess yeah and
then we got a dog and a dog ate there
out of it and that was the end of the
first pet there's also the first death I
had ever really experienced
this is morbid okay last one first time
realizing you were famous I was 15 years
old I had just moved to Los Angeles I
was at the AMC movie theater in Century
City with my mom they were walking
through the lobby and these girls came
up to me and they said are you Dallas
from Austin and Ally
do you play the cellphone accessory cart
guy and I was like yeah yeah yeah and
they're like can we have a picture with
you and I was like yeah of course like
sure thank you and we took pictures and
my mom was kind of just standing there
and being like that was I was like dang
dang alright guys my name is Noah since
now you can check out some of the stuff
that's coming out on Netflix Sierra
Burgess is a loser and to all the boys I
loved before please do it we're here at
BuzzFeed that's all my time with you I
love you guys so much thank you for
tuning in I hope to be back here and see
you guys very soon doses
[Music]